صواريخ روسيه تستهدف دانيبرو وسط اوكرانيا
فيما تحمل موسكو كيف مسؤوليه قصف في مدينه
الجيش السوداني يدعو متقاعديه لحمل السلاح
والامم المتحده ترفض طلبا للبرهان بتغيير
المبعوث الامامي الى بلاده
مفاوضات محمومه رغم الاجواء التفاؤليه
بايدن يامل في التوصل الى صيغه اتفاق مع
الجمهوريين لمعالجه ازمه سقف الدين
[موسيقى]
طابع صباحكم واليكم نشره لاهم الانباء من
العربيه اعلنت سلطات الاوكرانيه عن تعرض
مواقع مدنيه في دانيبرو الى قصف روسي حيث
استهدفت صواريخ روسيه مركزا طبيا في
دانيبرو اسفلت عن مقتل شخصين واصابه
العشرات بالاضافه الى الحاق اضرار ماديه
كبيره فيما قال حاكم دانيبرو ان هناك 30
جريحا بينهم طفلا وثلاثه اشخاص لا زالوا
مفقودين من جهته نشر الرئيس الاوكراني
فولوديلنسكي نشر صورا تظهر مباني مدمره
جزئيا تتصاعد منها اعمده الدخان ووصف
القصف الروسي بانه جريمه ضد الانسانيه
قالت فرق الانقاذ عناصرها ساعدت عددا من
المرضى على مغادره المركز الطبي عبر ممرات
مليئه بالركام
بوابه
وقد اظهرت صور حجم الاضرار في دانيبرو بعد
ضربه روسيه على المنطقه ما اسفر عن مقتل
شخصين واصابه ثلاثه وعشرين اخرين من بينهم
طفلان الهجوم تسببه في تضرر مستشفيين
وملعب ومدرسه اظهرت لقطات رجال الاطفاء
وهم يقومون بمكافحه السنه اللهب كما
المباني المدمره
[موسيقى]
من جانبي اعلن قائد مجموعه فاجن العسكريه
روسيه في
تكليف جديد لقواته يقضي بقتالهم على جبهه
جديده في اوكرانيا وقال بريجوجن ان روسيا
تحتاج للدفاع عنها لذا تم تكليفهم بهذا
الامر ياتي هذا بعد يوم واحد على انسحاب
عناصر فاجنر من مدينه بخمت في شرق
اوكرانيا وتسليمها للجيش الروسي
[موسيقى]
على الجانب الاخر اكد مراسل العربيه اسقاط
مسيرتين لعبوتين صفتين داخل الاراضي
الروسيه في منطقه دون حدوث اي اصابات
مضيفا لنا احدى العبوات الناسفه انفجرت
بينما الاخرى لم تنفجر بينما قالت حكومه
القرود عن توجه خبراء مختصين للتعامل مع
المتفجرات المنطقه لتحديد العبوه
روسيا التي تحارب في اوكرانيا والتي لها
علاقات متوتره مع الغرب في واجهتها
السياسيه والعسكريه مجموعه من الشخصيات
الى جانب الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ابرزهم
وزير الدفاع ووزير الخارجيه وقائد مجموعه
فاجنر في هذا التقرير نتابع اهم سمات هذه
الاسماء
خلف هذه الجدران تحاكي خيوط سياسه موسكو
كواليس بواجهه علنيه تمثلها خمس شخصيات
تتبادل الادوار فيما بينها بخصوص الازمه
الاوكرانيه او العلاقات المتوتره مع الغرب
الدفه يقودها الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين بصمته
الذي يخفي جبلا من الافكار والخطط خرجاته
تتراوح بين ممارسه الدبلوماسيه
البراجماتيه الهادئه والتهديد والوعيد سيد
الكريم قد يظهر هنا صامتا وهناك عبوسا
قمطريرا واضعا يده على زر اسلحه نوويه لا
تبقي ولا تذر
الى جانبه صديقه الكبير ورفيق دربه الرئيس
السابق
لغته تغلب عليها التهديدات لا يترك فرصه
الا ويتواعد الكل بالجحيم فروسيا مستعده
لتدمير كل شيء من اجل بقاء روسيا هي عقيده
تلقنها ويرددها باستمرار
قائد الحرب الاول وزير الدفاع سيرجي شويغو
احد الاعضاء القلائل في الدائره الاولى
للسلطه الذين كان لهم نفوذ كبير تحت حكم
بوروسيال في نهايه التسعينيات وتحت حكم
بوتين يظهر ثم يغيب يوصف بخادم القياصره
وابي الجنود كما يسمى بالحرباء المثاليه
القادره على التحول لتحقيق رغبه الحكام
خاصه بوتان
في ساحه المعركه الى جانب قوه شويغو
مجموعه فاجنر بقائدها المثير للجدل
او طباخ الرئيس وذراعه اليسرى في حربه
باوكرانيا ينتقد قياده الجيش في كل فرصه
تتاح له خاصه حينما انحى باللائمه على
القاده الروس بشان مقتل عشرات الالاف من
فاجنر لانهم لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي من
الذخيره
اما سفينه الدبلوماسيه فيقودها وزير
الخارجيه المخضرم سيرجي لافروف تراه في كل
موانئ عواصم العالم بحثا عن الدعم وربطا
للعلاقات وتفسيرا لقراره الكرملين
يشكك بكل شيء يدقق في التفاصيل والتعابير
معروف بتصريحاته القويه
وانتقاداته الشديده للغرب بلال البجداني
العربيه
من جهه اخرى اعلن الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش تجديد الثقه
برئيس بعثه الامم المتحده المتكامله لدعم
الانتقال في السودان
ردا على طلب رئيس مجلس السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان باقاله فولك بسبب ما قال
انه اصبح مصدرا انعكاسات سلبيه عن
الانطباع تجاه الامم المتحده قال غوتيرش
ان الامم المتحده مصدومه من طلب الجيش
السوداني بتغيير المبعوث الاممي
وكان رئيس مجلس سياده السودانيه عبد
الفتاح البرهان قد طالب الامم المتحده
باستبدال رئيس بعثتها المتكامله لدعم
الانتقال في السودان
وقال البرهان ان وجود فولكر اصبح مصرا
انعكاسات سلبيه عن الانطباع تجاه الامم
المتحده مضيفا ان ما قضاه فولكير على راس
البعثه لا يساعد في تنفيذ تفويض بالصوره
التي تسهم بالوصول لعمليه انتقال ناجحه
في السودان الجيش يطالب الامم المتحده
باقاله مبعوثها الاممي فولكر بيرس الجيش
السوداني فولكر بورتس شجع قائد قوات الدعم
السريع على التمرد فولكر بيرس مارست تضليل
في تقاريره حول الاتفاق الايطالي وجود
فولكر بيرس لا يدعم المرحله الانتقاليه في
السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان نطلب اختيار
بديل ليبرس حفاظا على العلاقه بين الامم
المتحده والسودان
طرفا الصراع في السودان يدركان ان استمرار
القتال لن يقود الى النتيجه المرجوه
ان الشمس مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
شركه ايلون ماسك لرقائق الدماغيه تحصل على
اذن لبدء التجارب على تركيبها في اجسام
البشر
اهلا بكم اعرب رئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن عن
املهم في التوصل الى اتفاق حول سداد الدين
مشيرا الى ان الامر اصبح قريبا
بالنسبه لسقف الدين الامور تبدو جيده وانا
متفائل وامل في الحصول على ادله واضحه
الليله للتوصل الى اتفاق لكن الامر قريب
وانا متفائل
المفاوضات بين البيت الابيض والجمهوريين
في مجلس النواب بشان سقف الدين مستمره مع
احراز تقدم لكن من دون اتفاق حتى الان
رئيس المجلس كابل مقر في اعرب عن تفائله
وقال ان المحادثات تتمحور الان حول
الانفاق مضيفا انه مازال هناك عمل يجب
القيام به
لم يرغب الديمقراطيون ابدا في وقف مقدار
انفاقهم يريدون فقط الاستمرار بذلك لا
اعتقد انه من الصواب ان تقترض اموالا من
الصين لدفع اموال للناس للبقاء في المنزل
هذه ليست الطريقه الامريكيه وساعمل قدر
المستطاع لمحاوله انجاز ذلك وتحقيق المزيد
من التقدم اليوم وانهاء المهمه
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اقترح
تخفيض الانفاق باكثر من تريليون دولار
وتجميد الانفاق خلال العامين المقبلين
وزياده الضرائب على الاثرياء والشركات
الكبرى وهو ما يرفضه الجمهوريون مطلعون
على المفاوضات افادوا بان الاتفاق المحتمل
سيرفع سقف الدين لعامين ويحد الانفاق
الفيدرالي على برامج حكوميه باستثناء ما
يتعلق بالقطاع العسكري والمحاربين القدامى
واشاروا الى التوصل الى تفاهم بشان تمويل
دائره الايرادات الداخليه
النقاط الخلافه تتعلق بمقدار التخفيضات في
البرامج المحليه وافق بيتا على التجميد اي
عدم زياده عن العمل الماضي في الميزانيه
الماليه القادمه بالرغم من ان التجميد من
الناحيه الفنيه هو نفس المبلغ من المال
الا انه لا يفسر ارتفاع تضخم واشياء اخرى
هذه الاشياء العالقه في هذه المرحله
لكن التسريبات حول الصفقه المحتمله اثارت
غضب الجمهوريين المحافظين وحذروا من
انهيار دعم الحزب لمكارفي اذا رفع سقف
الدين اكثر من ما اقترحوه من دون الحصول
على مزيد من التنازلات في المقابل ليس
الجمهوريون فقط من لديهم تحفظات بل حتى
بعض الديمقراطيين من الوسطيين والتقدميين
الذين حذروا البيت الابيض من تقديم
تنازلات قد تلحق الضرر بناخبهم حسين
الطاوضه العربيه واشنطن
وعلى صعيد معركه السباق رئاسيه سلاح سري
يمتلكه حاكم فلوريد الذي اعلن ترشحه رسميا
للانتخابات رئاسه الامريكيه حنكه سياسيه
وخبره رمبيه عززها بحضور زوجته المؤثره في
كل قراراته زوجته كيس اعتزلت الاعلام لتقف
خلفه بمشواره السياسي جامعه الاناقه وفن
التواصل مع الناخبين واللفت العاطفيه
والانسانيه التي يفتقدها الزوج
من قناه التواصل مع الجمهور تغمز كيسي
زوجه حاكم فلوريدا
مذيعه سابقه اخرجت من جعبتها ادوات المهنه
الرئيسيه ثقه بالنفس واناقه وحضور عززتهم
بمهاره التواصل مع الناخبين والراحه على
المنبر هذه الكاريزما الاعلاميه وظفتها
بالسياسه لدعم زوجها المرشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه
التي انتزعت خانه الزوجه عام 2009 احتلت
صفه الحاكم المساعد ومستشاره ديسانتس
الاولى التي لا تفارقه مقربون منه اكدوا
مشاركتها في كل قرار يتخذه لدرجه الخوف من
ابعاده عن مستشاريه المحترفين
انها ليست اذكى مستشاري واقربهم فحسب بل
هي سلاح السري
مقابلات ديسانتس المختلفه تكشف مدى
اعتماده على زوجته في تلطيف صورته كمحافظ
متشدد فتالقه بفقره الارقام والقوانين
تغنيه لمسه الزوجه بسرد الحكايات الشخصيه
وما تتخلله من مغامره منزليه لرجل العائله
اي الابا المحب والزوجه المتفاني لفته
عاطفيه تفتقدها شخصيه زوجها المحنك سياسيا
شعبيه كيسيدسانتس لا تقل عن زوجها اناقه
ماثلت زوجات رؤساء السابقين مثل جاكي
كاندي وميلانيا ترامب وتاثير سياسي تمت
مقارنتهيلاري كلينتون لتثير التساؤلات حول
امكانيه تحول السيده فلوريدا الاولى الى
سيده لجميع الولايات الامريكيه في حال
وصول زوجها للبيت الابيض طريق لا يزال
طويلا اولى محطته اللقاء بالزوجه المناسبه
او ما وصفه ديسانس باهم المصادفات السعيده
في حياته
سجلات مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه الامريكي
تحدثت عن تهديد خطير للملكه الراحله
اليزابيث الثانيه خلال احدى عشره زياره
الى الولايات المتحده ضمن فتره حكمها التي
استمرت سبعه عقود اليكم تفاصيل محاولات
اغتيال الملكه اليزابيث في التقرير التالي
ملكه بريطانيا الراحله الثانيه تعرضت لعده
محاولات اغتيال في الولايات المتحده
جميعها باءت بالفشل وثائقه صادره حديثا عن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه كشفت ان العقول
المدبره لهذه المحاولات كان يقف وراءها
الجيش الجمهوري الايرلندي اول محاوله
اغتيال تعود الى العام
1983 في ولايه سان فرانسيسكو عندما كانت
الملكه وزوجها الامير فيليب في زياره الى
كاليفورنيا حينها حذر ضابط شرطه المخابرات
الامريكيه من ان هناك رجلا يسعى للانتقام
لابنته التي قتلت برصاصه مطاطيه في
ايرلندا الشماليه
مخطط الرجل كان سيؤدي الى قتل الملكه
باستهداف يختي بريطانيا الملكي من فوق جسر
البوابه الذهبيه او بقتلها مباشره خلال
زيارتها لحديقه الوطنيه
اصل التوترات يرجع الى نهايه ستينات القرن
العشرين عندما عانت ايرلندا الشماليه حقبه
من العنف المميت عرفت باسم حقبه المشكلات
استمرت 30 سنه وقد وضعت بذرتها قرون من
الصراع بين ايرلندا الكاثوليكيه وانجلترا
البروتستانتيه
فمع اشتداد الصراع في ايرلندا الشماليه
ظلت الولايات المتحده في حاله تاهب قسوه
كلما زارها افراد العائله الملكه
البريطانيه لتجنب اي تداعيات على اراضيها
وخاصه بعد الكشف عن محاوله اغتيال اخرى
للملكه خلال زيارتها الى بوستن ونيويورك
في عام 1989
بعد ذلك بعامين كشفت الاستخبارات
الامريكيه عن مخاوفها من ان الجماعات
الايرلنديه حسب وصفها كانت تخطط للاحتجاج
رفضا لحضور اليزابيث الثانيه
للبيت الابيض عام 1991
تعاني محافظه تعز اليمنيه من تزايد عدد
حالات سوء التغذيه الحاد الوخيب بعد
انخفاض دعم المنظمات الانسانيه بشكل كبير
وانسحاب بعضها من مراكز متعدده في المدينه
وسجل مكتب الصحه بالمحافظه اكثر من 22 الف
حاله مصابه بسوء التغذيه خلال العام
الماضي فيما سجل الثلاثه اشهر الاولى من
هذا العام اكثر من 4000 حاله هذا وارتفع
عدد سوء حالات التغذيه الحاد الوخير
بالنسبه 5% هذا العام
كاد يفقد حياته جوعا في مناطق سيطره
الحوثيين فاستدعى اسعافه عاجلا الى تعز
لقد فضلت اسرتهم للزوحه من اب الى المدينه
هذه بحثا عن رعايه صحيه تنقذ طفلها من
هلاك سوء التغذيه انه مؤشر الى تدهور صحي
بات يهدد حياه مئات الاطفال في المناطق
الخاضعه لسيطره الميليشيات الحوثيه
نجحنا الان علشان
نعالج اطفالنا نسوي الولد هذا تعبان كيف
حالته يعني شو تغذيه تعبان
ما اقدر تعالجه ولا تقدر تسوي شيء هذا
الطفل عنده احد وخيم يعاني من جفاف واسهال
شديد
وعنده نقص في الاكسجين وضربات القلب
[موسيقى]
تتسع اذا دائره الفقر في البلد وتزداد
معها حالات الاصابه بسوء التغذيه الحاده
ففي تعز وحدها استقبلت المستشفيات خلال
ثلاثه اشهر فقط اكثر من 5000 حاله سبع
منها فارقت الحياه ويبقى سته ملايين طفل
في اليمن على بعد خطوه واحده من المجاعه
كونهم بحاجه ماسه لدعم عاجل بحسب تحذيرات
لمنظمه اليونسيف في خلال الربع هذا ازدادت
الحالات الى ما يقارب الخمسه في المئه
اصبح لدينا في خلال هذه الفترات 23 الف
حاله
مترددين في في
على المستشفيات تعز في حالات وخيمه حالات
تصارع الموت
ووفقا لنتائج التصنيف المرحلي للامن
الغذائي بالمحافظه فان الوضع بات خارجا في
المدينه ومديريه الساحل الغربي خصوصا مع
انخفاض دعم المنظمات بشكل كبير وانسحاب
بعضها من الاقسام الخاصه بامراض سوء
التغذيه في مستشفيات خليفه والمصراخ
والشقيرات غربي تعز هل سعيد العربيه تعز
قالت شركه نيورالينك المملوكه من
الملياردير الامريكي ايلون ماسك والتي
تنوي تجربه زراعه شريحه الكترونيه في دماغ
بشري ان حصلت على الضوء الاخضر من اداره
الغذاء والدواء الامريكيه لبدء اول تجربه
سريريه على الانسان
شريحه ايلون ماسك للادمغه نيروليت ابتكار
تكنولوجي جديد حصل على موافقه من اداره
الغذاء والدواء لاجراء اول تجربه سريريه
على البشر شريحه يورالينك ستوضع في ادمغه
البشر بهدف السماح للعقل البشري بالتحكم
في الاجهزه الالكترونيه المعقده ومساعده
الاشخاص المصابين بالشلل على استعاده
الوظيفه الحركيه واستعاده الرؤيه لفاقدي
البصر وعلاج امراض الدماغ الاخرى هذا يعني
السماح لمن يعانون من انعدام القدره على
الحركه بالتواصل عبر افكارهم الشريحه
الدماغيه تترجم النشاط العصبي الى بيانات
يمكن تفسيرها بواسطه الكمبيوتر
رغم ذلك لا يزال الخبراء يشككون بشان جدوى
هذه الشريحه وقالوا ان الامر اقرب للخيال
العلمي
نيورولي واجهت فضائح عديده منذ اوائل
العام الماضي من ضمنها اجراء تجارب غير
اخلاقيه على القرود
تسبب الاعصار مارب بدمار هائل في جزيره
غوام الامريكيه مدفع السلطات لاعلان حاله
الطوارئ ويتوقع ان تشتد قوه الاعصار الذي
يعد الاقوى في العالم خلال العام الجاري
بسرعه رياح تجاوزت 185 ميلا في الساعه
الاعصار موار يتحول الى اقوى اعصار في
العالم عام 2023
الاعصار الفائق اجبر بايدن على اعلان حاله
الطوارئ بعد ان ضرب جزيره غواام
الجزيره البالغ عدد سكانها
168 الفا تضم ثلاثه قواعد عسكريه امريكيه
تسبب الاعصار بدمار هائل في الجزيره امر
دفع السلطات لاعلانها جزيره منكوبه
وكاله الارصاد الامريكيه حذرت من تشكل
موجات كبيره قد يصل ارتفاعها 15 قدما
مع توجه الاعصار الى الفلبين يتوقع ان
يتكثف مع مروره غربي المحيط الهادئ
توقعات خبراء الارصاد الجويه تقول ان
الاعصار سيشتد ليصبح اكثر قوه ودمارا
هذا وتسببت الامطار الغزيره في الشمال
الايطالي في سقوط وفيات واضرار امتدت الى
جنوب البلاد
في نهايه النشره هذا تذكير بالعناوين
صواريخ روسيه تستهدف دانيبرو وسط اوكرانيا
فيما تحمل موسكو كييف مسؤوليه قصف مدينه
الجيش السوداني يدعم متقاعديه الى حمل
السلاح والامم المتحده ترفض طلبا للبرهان
بتغيير المبعوث الامامي الى بلاده
مفاوضات محمومه رغم الاجواء التفاؤليه
فبعيدن يامل في التوصل الى صيغه اتفاق مع
الجمهوريين لمعالجه ازمه سقف الدين
والى هنا تنتهي هذه النشره الاخباريه نشره
جديده بعد دقائق تحيه لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات